Homère m'a tué on m'a mis en texte
entre Iliade et Odyssée
c'est là que je suis mort
pourtant mes premières expériences étaient
des plus modestes
on m'invitait au coin d'un feu je
passais de conteur en conteur
j'égayais enfants et adolescents, je donnais
parfois des vocations je consolais les
coeurs meurtris
et puis tout est allé très vite
d'histoire de grand-père j'ai été
propulsé en légende dorée jusqu'à
devenir la source de la culture
européenne
j'espère qu'un jour on me ressuscitera
que l'on comprendra qu'elle était ma raison
d'être ici bas
sachez que le mythe se dit plus qu'il ne se lit
c'est la bouche
à l'oreille qui m'anime le voyage qui m'endurcit
indomptable par nature je
suis un chant qui danse
le Minotaure monstre mythologique
moitié homme moitié taureau avait droit
tous les neuf ans à sept jeunes
athéniens et sept jeunes athéniennes
livrés en sacrifice
face à cette barbarie
Thésée, héros athénien décide d'affronter
le Minotaure pour mettre fin à cette
tradition
il sort victorieux de ce combat et
réussi à sortir du labyrinthe avec
l'aide d'Ariane la fille du roi de Crète
Minos et libère Cnossos de cet horrible
sort
voilà le récit qui devait se raconter un
peu partout sur les places publiques
dans les tavernes et les marchés antiques
mais quelle crédibilité déjà chez les
grecs anciens pouvait-on lui accorder ?
et
derrière la légende du Minotaure peut-on
déceler une part de vérité ?
le site archéologique de Cnossos abrite
des bâtiments minoens daté d'il y a
environ quatre mille ans
ce qui fait la célébrité de ce lieu se sont en
particulier ses palais ses fresques et
le lieu supposé du labyrinthe du
Minotaure
Cnossos est une cité
entourée de mystères et de légendes
Minos et Pasiphaé
Ariane et Thésée,
le Minotaure
et le labyrinthe
redécouverte en 1900 par
Arthur Evans anthropologue et archéologue
anglais qui exhume avec son équipe un
édifice de 1200 pièces
la cité sera très
vite associée au légendaire roi Minos et
son labyrinthe mystérieux construit par
Dédale
un dédale c'est justement le
terme pour décrire le parcours que
n'importe quel touriste expérimente en
mettant pour la première fois les pieds
ici
un enchaînement sans fin de couloirs
d'escalier de cours à plusieurs entrées
et une fatigue qui vous touche assez
rapidement
la difficulté de circulation
et d'orientation peut donc faire penser
à la forme labyrinthique
vu du ciel
c'est assez flagrant mais ce plan est
finalement assez classique et on
retrouve cet agencement pour les autres
cités et de l'âge du bronze en
Méditerranée sans parler
systématiquement d'un labyrinthe
That side
autre intérêt du site les fresques le
mobilier et les sculptures
de l'or, des peintures
représentant des minoens à
moitié nus entourés de nourriture
des céramiques à foison et surtout des
représentations de taureaux
l'édifice qui a donc fait parler de lui au début
des fouilles est le palais ou megaron
qui veut dire grande salle c'est
un bâtiment très reconnaissable par des
façades monumentale et un foyer central
entouré de plusieurs colonnes
tout autour il y a des entrepôts des halls et
des couloirs d'accès
à partir des objets précieux exhumés
on a voulu y voir le
palais des souverains de la Crète minoenne
Des grandes salles pouvait
accueillir le trône d'autres pièces des
fontaines et bains luxueux et puis plus
loin il y avait un théâtre appelé petit
palais qui offrait des spectacles et
notamment des tauromachies
pour divertir l'élite
c'est en tout cas la version qu'en a
donnée Evans qui attribua à sa
découverte le nom de "labyrinthe du palais de Cnossos"
la renommée du site
était faite
depuis les chercheurs sont
revenus sur cette première
interprétation un peu trop belle pour
être historique et tente de comprendre
la véritable fonction des palais minoens
visiblement le terme palais peut prêter
à confusion car rien ne prouve qu'il
s'agisse du lieu de vie des rois
ces grands édifices auraient tout aussi pu
assumer une fonction religieuse ou
funéraire
A en croire les objets exposés au
musée d'Héraklion très rares sont
ceux rattachés aux pratiques de la vie courante
trop beaux pas assez pratiques et surtout
pas assez utilisés
il est peut-être
facile de toujours choisir la piste du
religieux quand on n'a pas idée de la
fonction d'un lieu mais Cnossos
n'est pas un cas unique
d'autres cités crétoises présentent les
mêmes dispositifs architecturaux et sont
aussi richement dotées
Phaistos, Hagia Triada, Malia, Zakros
semblent avoir été
des centres religieux et pas des
résidences luxueuses pour souverain en
villégiature
avec ce nouvel angle de vue on peut
appréhender différemment Cnossos
et voir dans ce matériel luxueux des
offrandes et faire de ces innombrables
pièces des salles de rituels de
cérémonie peut-être de préparation des
corps avant inhumation et un lieu de
recueillement des familles
on comprend ainsi mieux l'absence de
rempart, de fossé ou de tourelle
puisque personne n'attaque un lieu sacré
il est évident que la mythologie a
largement influencé Evans et son équipe
d'archéologues
à l'époque en 1900 en
exhumant le palais il est persuadé qu'il
s'agit de celui du roi Minos plus qu'une
découverte archéologique majeure
cette mise au jour replacée dans son
contexte historique prend une valeur
philosophique
retrouver le palais de Minos
c'est aussi faire ressurgir le
mythe du Minotaure
une thèse qui n'est pas vraiment au goût
de l'époque pour beaucoup de
scientifiques de la fin du 19e siècle et
du début du 20ème
les histoires de sacrifices humains de
monstres fantastiques et anthropophages
n'avaient rien de vraisemblables
le Minotaure n'avait pas sa place dans la
pensée humaniste et n'était qu'un
symbole de la consécration de la Grèce
hellénistique sur un culte archaïque
dans cette logique le labyrinthe n'était
plus qu'une simple invention d'un poète
grec à l'imagination débordante
bref pas de place dans le monde de la
science pour la barbarie même
mythologique
le contexte tient donc une part
indéniable dans le déroulement des
fouilles de Cnossos qui se déroule
jusqu'à la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale
à la sortie de ce conflit
la redécouverte d'une civilisation riche
se représentant sur les fresques, nue
maquillée dans un lieu ensoleillé
tranchait fortement avec la crise
existentielle que venait de vivre
l'Europe
le touriste de l'après-guerre qui
visitait Cnossos et les rivages de la
Méditerranée ne pouvait pas faire de
nouveau face à ces cruautés passées celles
des sacrifices humains
il fallait taire le mythe du minotaure
les crétois des fresques anciennes était
un modèle d' existence insouciante
loin des camps de la mort
par des choix stylistiques de
restitution les fouilleurs ont mis en
avant un mythe celui de la royauté
prospère plutôt que celle du
Minotaure insatiable
aujourd'hui quand on visite
Cnossos
on a la sensation d'être dans un
disneyland archéologique en béton pour
reprendre les mots du géologue Wunderlich
des colonnes de béton du rouge tape à l'oeil
et des sculptures tout
propres
c'était l'esthétisme de l'époque d'Evans, de la Belle Époque
d'ailleurs la plupart des restitutions
architecturales et artistiques qu'à
commandées Evans sont aujourd'hui
contestées par l'archéologie
finalement
qu'avons-nous appris à Cnossos ?
qu'il n'y a malheureusement pas de preuve
de l'existence d'un homme taureau
dommage
mais aussi que ce qui est aujourd'hui
présenté comme un labyrinthe en
référence aux aventures de Thésée n'est rien
d'autre qu'un plan classique de grands
complexes de l'Antiquité que ce soit en
Asie Mineure en Mésopotamie
en Égypte
des salles étroites car
difficiles à couvrir sans recourir à des
voûtes procédé inconnu à cette
époque
d'ailleurs des fresques de taureau
encore une fois il n'ya rien de
plus commun en Méditerranée et ce dès le
plus ancien néolithique soit des
millénaires avant Cnossos
enfin si on laisse de côté l'idée du Minotaure, il n'est même pas sûr que
ce lieu était un palais royal ou en tout
cas il n'a pas été que cela
le mythe a donc totalement déformé notre
vision du site
obnubilés par cette histoire fameuse
nous voulons y trouver
ce que nous connaissons déjà
quitte à oublier sa réalité plus
complexe
c'est un risque auquels d'autres lieux mythiques n'échappent pas
et nous
verrons ça dans le prochain épisode